[Music]
my name is Stephan sorrow you and
together with my colleague Alec woman
where the session co-chairs for this
security session and I'm sure all of you
are here to find out the kind of work
that both Microsoft and academia has
been doing on these kinds of attacks
that's them from speculative executions
for CPUs like meltdown inspector or from
the density of the cells packed in
theorem like Rho hammer I was really
hoping to have a discussion throughout
the talk we're gonna have three speakers
and I'm we're going to introduce each of
them I still encourage you I think it's
gonna be difficult and the reason for
that is because I think the dynamics of
this room really is not amenable to the
kind of discussions I would like to have
nevertheless I strongly encourage you to
raise your hand and ask questions if you
like in the middle of the talk and we
have ample time for Q&A at the end of
each each presentation okay okay so it's
my pleasure to introduce to the first
speaker christopher turtle he's a
security software engineer in what's
called nsrc at Microsoft MSR systems for
Microsoft Response Center and this is
the team that deals with security
vulnerabilities especially in Azure but
I'm is your is your guys bandages for
Azure or for the whole Microsoft know so
it's for all Microsoft products
including browser office etc okay so and
he's gonna talk a little bit about you
know some of the things that Microsoft's
been doing to mitigate meltdown
inspector thank you all right thank you
Stefan
so good morning everyone once again my
name is Christopher Otto I'm gonna be
talking about the specter of meltdown
vulnerabilities and how we're able to
mitigate them
all right so specter and meltdown these
issues gained a huge amount of interest
from the research community when they
were disclosed in January this year and
the reason for that is because they
represent a fundamentally new class of
hardware security vulnerability which
allows leaking information across
security boundaries from the browser the
hypervisor etc all right so when we were
first made available of these issues in
June last year we kicked off our
incident response process and this is
typical for whenever we're made
available
we're made aware of a critical security
vulnerability either being exploited in
the wild or just a high threat which
requires mobilizing a large number of
people within Microsoft to drive
remediation of the fixers so specter and
meltdown
once again they apply to they have
implications across nearly every
security boundary and allow potentially
disclosing information such as passwords
in the browser or a guest to guests in
virtualization context so what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna break down
the attacks themselves more generally
how speculative execution can lead to a
side Channel and then afterwards we can
go on to how we might be able to
mitigate those all right so before we
can get into a speculative execution
itself I'm going to need to explain a
bit about how a modern CPU works so
typically when we see assembly code and
we consider how CPU executes we
generally think of each instruction
executing one after the other
sequentially but in reality it's a bit
more complicated than this instructions
are first decoded into a series of micro
operations which are placed into a
reorder buffer and from there the CPU is
able to make use of several
optimizations so the first of which is
being superscalar it's able to execute
certain micro operations in parallel
concurrently the second which is out of
order execution and this essentially
allows the CPU to start executing later
instructions before earlier ones to make
best use of the available execution
units and yeah this is faster than just
waiting for each instruction to complete
before the next one can start
so speculative execution is just an
extension of outer water execution so
the CPU is so when the CPU has some kind
of dependency on the results of an
operation rather than waiting for that
to be to resolve and the results be made
available it can begin executing
speculatively according to a prediction
that it makes on this outcome and the
reasoning behind this is that once the
result is made available and we can if
the prediction was correct the results
of speculative execution can be
committed so that's the calculated
register values and any memory stores
for example and this is much quicker
than waiting for there was waiting for
the outcome to be made available before
starting execution conversely if the
prediction that speculation ran on was
incorrect the results will be discarded
and execution unrolled all right so the
fundamental problem was speculative
execution which led to the specter and
meltdown vulnerabilities is that not
everything is thrown away when
speculative execution when incorrect
speculative execution is unrolls
in particular changes to the cache state
and not always unrolled and that can
contain private data which an attacker
might be able to later observe all right
so now I'm going to move on to the
variants themselves so starting with
variant one this was where a conditional
branch would mispredict
so here we have a typical balance check
trip on an untrusted index before using
it as an array index for this buffer and
this is a typical code pattern very
common in C and C++ code but consider if
this bounced check is Miss predicted and
the inner code is executed was untrusted
index is actually greater than or equal
to length in this case what will happen
is value will be read
from depending on the types involved
this could be an arbitrary virtual
address considering if buff is a bike
pointer and untrusted index is a 64-bit
value this could result in reading value
from an arbitrary virtual address and
then after that a second array index
will be performed which loads a
different cache line depending on this
private value so the result of this is
that if an attacker can execute this
code speculatively the different cache
line will be loaded as an artifact of
that secret value that should not be
made available variant 2 was where the
target of an indirect branch would be
mispredicted so indirect branches are
used when the compiler doesn't know at
compile time what the target of the
branch will be so typically a function
pointer or a V table for example and if
speculative execution executes one of
these indirect branches on a register it
might jump to the to an incorrect target
and similar to before what might happen
is reading a bite from an attacker
controlled register and then loading a
cache line according to this secret
value and cache line size is 64 bytes so
in this gadget we simply shift it left
six times so variant three we're
specific to the kernel to user
information disclosure scenario so if
these last three instructions are
executing speculatively due to
conditional branch mispredict for
example what can happen is that if we
try to load from kernel memory in user
land execution speculative execution
will actually be able to retrieve that
value and pass it onto subsequent
instructions before the exception will
be triggered and so it can persist the
results by loading a cache line for
example as we saw before and
with this variant userland code
execution is able to read kernel memory
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to create a taxonomy of these kind of
attacks and so we can systematically go
through the key components required and
then move on to the mitigations all
right so there are four key components
required for a speculative execution
side-channel the first of which is a
method of gaining speculation so as we
saw that might be conditional branch
misprediction 'pl and the second thing
we'll need is a window and gadget and
this is used to extend how long
speculation can run before the CPU
realizes it was speculating with an
incorrect value prediction value the
third thing we need is a disclosure
gadget to persist the results made
during speculative execution so as we
saw that might be loading a cache line
according to a private value and finally
we need a way to observe those results
to determine for example which cache
line was loaded and from that and
further secret that was loaded during
speculative execution and if any one of
these four parts are not present the
speculative execution side channel will
not be able to succeed so starting with
speculation techniques we have the three
from the three variants reported we have
conditional branch mispredict
and this doesn't have to be a bounced
check this can be any conditional branch
so for example a type check could lead
to speculative type confusion if miss
predicted but the thing is these
conditional branches can be trained
based on past behavior so we can make it
very likely that a speculative execution
will take the conditional roots the
conditional path we desire during
speculation variant two was the indirect
branch misprediction similarly as the
CPU executes it maintains what's called
the BTB the branch target buffer which
maintains a list of branch targets
during execution and speculative
execution will use this internal buffer
to predict where to jump we can also
collide different different entries so
we can have two different addresses that
point to the same internal BTB entry and
finally meltdown was where the CPU can
invoke a camp perform for example a
kernel load from userland and Ford the
result of that onto subsequent micro
operations before the permission Fault
will be delivered alright so now that
we're able to trigger speculation we
need a window and gadget and once again
this is required so that speculation can
can execute for long enough that we are
able to just to persist the results by
reaching a disclosure catch up so the
key point here is that when doing
gadgets can naturally occur in code they
can be something as simple as dependency
chain of arithmetic operations for
example or more commonly even just
forming an uncashed load all right so
with speculation running we can now
begin to see how a side channel can be
formed from this so a side channel has
three stages generally the first is
priming the system into a known initial
state the second is triggering or
waiting for some victim activity to
occur and finally an attacker will need
to observe whether the state changed to
infer information about what happened
during the victim activity so in the
context of speculative execution the
disclosure gadget will typically be
loading a cache line according to some
secret value which might have been read
out of bounds for example so for a flash
memory load primitive what an attacker
will do is they will first flush an
array of cache lines the disclosure
gadget will then load one of those
according to a secret and finally the
disclosure primitive will time how long
it takes to load each of those cache
lines and whichever ones faster as
likely to be loaded into the cache and
from that we can infer
what the secret value was during
speculative execution all right so just
to sum up again the force components of
a speculation attack we have the
speculation primitive the windowing
gadget the disclosure gadget and the
disclosure primitive and once again we
need all four of these to be able to
leak information through a side channel
alright so relevance to software
security very and three is specific to
the kernel to user information
disclosure scenario that's exception
delivery but all the others generally
apply universally across the board and
so I'm gonna need mitigations for those
all right so now that we understand
exactly what how speculative execution
can lead to a side channel attack we can
begin to go into the mitigations that we
can put in place for these so we have
three tactics the first is preventing
speculation techniques and specifically
what we mean by this is we want to
prevent unsafe speculation where
speculative execution can lead to a
disclosure gadget the second is removing
sensitive content from memory so this is
limiting what speculative execution will
be able to read this can eliminate
entire scenarios or simply reduce the
risk from certain scenarios and finally
removing observation channels this is
making it more difficult or even
impossible for an attacker to infer what
changes were made to the cache state
during speculative execution but once
again there's no silver bullet we
require a combination of different
hardware and software and mitigations
for each of the scenarios present so
starting with preventing speculation
techniques and once again the goal here
is to prevent a speculation primitive
from leading to a disclosure gadget the
first thing we can do is use some kind
of serialization of the instruction
pipeline so on x86 we have the elephants
instruction which has the neat property
of acting as a speculation barrier
so if we go back to variant 1 we see
this bounce check on an untrusted index
what we can do is in certain elephants
as a speculation barrier here after the
check and what this will guarantee is
that these subsequent two array indexes
will not be executed until speculation
has resolved to this point so this code
will never execute speculatively with
untrusted index out of bounds the second
thing we can do is have some kind of
implicit serialization so this is
forcing safe behavior down an
architectural e incorrect path so going
back to the variant 1 what we can do is
considering if this code executes the
inner code executes s-- even when
untrusted index is out of bounds we can
use conditional move instruction to set
untrusted index to this zeroed register
if it is greater than or equal to length
and what this will do is it will make
the behavior of speculative execution
safe because it will simply load 0 from
this buffer which is going to be in
bounds for doing this we have the cue
specter command line flag in visual C++
and this will automatically identify
potentially vulnerable patterns and
insert appropriate serialization
similarly in Microsoft edge we have
mitigations in the chat for a JavaScript
engine which inserts serialization to
prevent an attacker from being able to
construct these patterns the second
thing we can do is have some kind of
workload isolation so we talks about the
branch target buffer typically this
prediction these kind of prediction
states you should either per core or
personal taneous multi thread in the
case of simultaneous multi-threading
such as Intel hyper-threading so what we
can do is in hyper-v we can use CPU
groups and min routes to assign a
certain core to a particular
guest and then the others for the host
what this will what this will do is it
since the branch prediction state will
never be shared is not shared between
the host and the guest the guest will a
malicious guests will have no way of
colliding the branch prediction state so
the next thing is with the recent micro
code updates provided by Intel and AMD
we have some new model specific
registers which can control indirect
branches so we have IBRS first of all
which essentially acts as a way of
allowing of creating two different
privilege privileges so you can set IBRS
to zero for the less privilege state and
then on kernel entry for example you can
set it to one and this will create the
guarantee that the more privileged state
will not be able to be influenced by
predictions made in the less privileged
state the next thing we have is IB PB
which essentially allows us to flush to
flush the prediction State and this can
be used when switching between different
hypervisor contexts for example to
prevent different contexts from
poisoning each other's prediction state
finally we have STI BP which once again
a certain prediction state will be
shared among two sibling hyper threads
on a single core when we set STI BP to 1
it just offers the guarantee that
sibling hyper threads won't be able to
poison each other's of branch prediction
state all supported versions of Windows
client make use of these by default the
next thing we can do is use the final
thing to prevent speculation techniques
we can do is use safely speculated or
non speculated indirect branches so on
Intel CPUs the far jump and far
instructions which are indirect jumps
which change the segment will not be
predicted and so we can replace indirect
as with these and that will that will
prevent variant two similarly for AMD we
can use this elephants serialization
instruction which will guarantee that
the behavior is safe during speculation
and finally we have this proposal from
Google for a rep alene and this allows
us this acts as a way of allowing
catching speculative speculative
execution in an infinite loop while the
architectural route will form the
indirect jump as usual for the
hypervisor and Windows kernel were
exploring combination of these to make
best use of performance for removing
sensitive content from memory the goal
is once again to limit entire attack
scenarios or just limit the risk as best
possible so the first thing we can do is
have hypervisor address space
segregation so what this means is that
the hypervisor will only ever map guest
physical memory on demand as it's needed
and as opposed to historically were
offers all guest memory was always
mapped and what this means is that if a
guest if a guest VM performs a hyper
call into the hypervisor only its own
guest memory will be mapped a
speculation and the hypervisor will not
be able to read any memory of other
guests the next thing we have is KB a
shadow so this apply specifically to
barian 3 previously the user mode
execution we have the kernel page table
entries mapped but just marked as
inaccessible what we do with kV a shadow
is when transitioning between them we
ensure that the user mode execution
never has the kernel page table entries
mapped and what this means is that
speculative execution in user mode will
not be able to read kernel memory
because it's not physically present
all supported versions of windows client
make use of this and the final tactic we
have is removing observation channels so
once again the goal here is to make it
difficult or impossible for an attacker
to observe changes made during
speculative execution first thing we can
do is we can map guest physical memory
as uncatchable in the hypervisor so here
we have some system physical memory in
the guest it's still mac marked as
marked as write-back cache and so
there'll be no performance impact for
the guest itself but in the hypervisor
we map it as uncatchable what this means
is that a speculative execution and the
hypervisor attempts to perform a load
since it's marked as uncatchable memory
it will never bring that into the cache
and this acts as as a generic mitigation
for host to guest flush and reload which
requires shared cache lines the next
thing we can do is we can ensure that we
never share any physical memory between
guests so similarly we want to prevent
flush and reload between guests so we
just ensure that each guest has its own
copy of everything in physical memory
and so they can never influence each
other's cache state final thing we can
do is we can decrease browser time of
precision so those this API performance
start now accessible from JavaScript
which could be used to time a single
load and determine whether that that
memory that it was loading was in the
cache or not what we do is we decrease
the precision of this and add random
jitter to prevent cloth edging
techniques and so it is now impossible
for an attacker to infer whether or not
a single load is in the cache or not
alright so closing remarks I just want
to sum up once again that there's no
silver bullet for each of the scenarios
present we're going to require a
different combination of mitigations
once again going over the variants
they're all hardware vulnerabilities
variant one is going to require software
changes so that might be adding
appropriate serialization by the
compiler variant two is mitigated by the
OS making use of the indirect branch
controls as we saw and finally variant
three this was the kernel to user
information disclosure meltdown and that
is completely mitigated now with KVA
shadow alright so since then we've been
made aware of some new variants we have
speculative stall bypass which made use
of miss predicting data dependencies
between load and store instructions this
can be mitigated by identifying
vulnerable code patterns and inserting
instruction serialization once again it
can also be can also be mitigated by
disabling this memory to some big uation
optimization by the CPU but this is not
done by default because there are
currently no known exploitable patterns
in Windows code
second thing second variant is lazy
floating-point state restore so this was
an optimization made by the operating
system
when context switching between processes
the floating-point registers would not
be copied they would simply be marked as
inaccessible and then the first time
they were made made use of this would
trigger an exception where the kernel
would restore them or how to mitigate
this we just disable this optimization
and the floating-point registers are
always copied then we have bounced check
bypass store this was similar to variant
one if we have a conditional branch
misprediction leading to an outer bound
store if that store corrupts an indirect
branch target that can leave an attacker
with arbitrary speculation as an
arbitrary address the way we mitigate
that is just by adding speculation
barriers again similar to a varying one
and finally we have net specter which is
the first kind of speculative execution
side-channel
not using the cache that was timing the
AVX instructions the mitigation for that
is once again just using a speculation
area in vulnerable patterns we we expect
first speculative execution site channel
vulnerabilities to be continuing source
of research and so we have our
speculative execution side channel
bounty max payout is 250 K for new
variants we also have on tech nets and
blogs with more technical analysis of
any of the variants as well as developer
guidance alright so thanks for listening
and thank you to everyone who's worked
on this it's been a tremendous
undertaking thank you
[Applause]
so I'm I'm gonna ask you a question if
Oh Chris sorry right there okay yeah
Chris expensive or the various
mitigations okay
how expensive are the various
mitigations so that depends on the
operating system itself and your how
recent your CPU is so from our analysis
the latest Windows 10 with a modern
processor from within two years is less
than 10% for older operating systems
such as Windows 7 where there are some
differences for example the kernel the
kernel does all the font pausing there
is more kernel to user transition that's
slightly more expensive but yeah the
latest Windows 10 with a modern
processor the performance impact is not
that noticeable
it's single-digit there's more an hour
there's more analysis on our website if
you want more details so you told us
about this complex grid of mitigations
where it seems like it's hard to tell if
you're done filling out that grid and
coming up with all the relevant advice
to avoid security problems and I wonder
how much of this you think is coming
about because the hardware is is closed
to us and we can't even in principle do
an end-to-end foundational analysis of
security and could this be some
motivation for adopting more open source
hardware good question so we have been
working with Intel we have a
nondisclosure agreement with them so we
have some information but yeah
absolutely some details are not known to
us that's why we rely on our bounty
partly for
more information to be made available to
us and we'll react as best we can thank
you for your question sure I also also
have questions along the lines like you
know sort of similar my question was a
variant of your question right I mean I
think it's not not unlikely that within
the next year so there's gonna be yet
another speculative execution what way
of doing special speculative execution
to exploit kernels right so and it looks
like the process we have in place right
now is is you know hopefully they're not
gonna release it to the public where
ever discovered is this and hopefully it
gives time to the Microsoft and Google's
of the world to go patch the kernel sort
in the apples of the world to go patch
the kernels it seems pretty sad to me I
don't know it seems like it's that state
of affairs so do you have is there any
investment into having a more you know
principled solution to these things like
you were mentioning you know sort of
disclosing open source open sourcing
hardware it's on some way it's very nice
on the other hand like Intel can he's
probably not gonna do that anytime soon
so it's just sort of it's closed to me
that were kind of stuck with a bad
situation on our hands
so the medications we have in place
designed to not only mitigate existing
vectors but also to proactively consider
reducing the attack surface as much as
possible so as we saw the indirect
branch controls we can flush the
prediction state regularly as well as
others but yeah we have our own internal
research it's ongoing and will continue
to mitigate it as best possible
Thanks so I had another question um so
it seems like a bunch of the mitigations
that you mentioned require for instance
modifying binaries so that certain
instruction sequences have the
appropriate protections getting them but
presumably there are situations where
where customers who who are potentially
even attackers are allowed to load their
own code that they've compiled or
written in assembly and so in terms of
mitigations has there been any any
thought into what can be done to address
those kinds of situations yeah a very
good question so you mentioned
situations where an attacker is able to
supply their own code so for example one
of those scenarios is in the browser
where there we're running arbitrary
JavaScript from an attacker as I
mentioned chakram the JavaScript engine
of Edge has its own heuristics to detect
patterns such as variant 1 and it's an
appropriate serialization more generally
than that though you mentioned that
within Microsoft we have a lot of code
and rebuilding the whole world isn't
always possible that's why we have a
combination of mitigations just aiming
to mitigate the problem as best as
possible
yeah also for hypervisor scenario we
have mitigations from guest to guest as
I talked about so really it's just
limiting the severity of the attacks and
yeah doing as much as we can hopefully
that answered your question like I guess
I'm looking for a slightly higher level
answer in the following sense does the
current state of affairs keep you up at
night so I can be relatively happy with
the mitigation I think at the moment the
mitigations are pretty strong once again
we have our bounty so if real world
attacks are submitted to us they might
be illegible for a bounty and we'll try
to mitigate them as best as possible but
once again it's a continuing ongoing
matter of research and so at the moment
I think we're well protected but we're
ready to react if more information
becomes available to us are there any no
public instances of meltdown or specter
attacks that have been sort of rather
than proof of concepts you know
researchers showing look you can do this
to my knowledge we have and my question
is not just about Microsoft it's just in
general like if you happen to know yeah
to my knowledge I don't think these
attacks are being actively used in the
wild right now but what we see from our
detection is only a small sample so I
think it's possible in the future they
might be used by attackers in in
real-world scenarios but I can't comment
further right now
any other questions
okay let's uh let's think speaker thank
you okay our next speaker is Professor
Margaret Martin OC from Princeton
University and her research interests
are computer architecture and mobile
computing with a particular focus on
power efficient systems her current
research is focusing on the hardware
software on hardware software interface
approaches to managing heterogeneous
parallelism and power performance
trade-offs in systems ranging all the
way from smartphones all the way up to
large-scale data centers Professor
Martin OC is a fellow of I Triple E and
ACM and she's won numerous awards I'll
just mention two she won in 2015 she won
the iske long term influential paper
award and in 2017 the ACM Sigma will
attest to the time award and take it
away Morgan thank you good morning
everyone so this follows nicely from the
wonderful previous talk because the pre
news talk sort of gave us a state of
play and what I'm going to try to give
here is some thoughts that relate a bit
to your question about our attempt at a
principled way to forward so this story
parts of this story do start in January
with spectra and meltdown but a lot of
the story starts much earlier and I'm
going to take you through the flow from
our earlier work verifying memory
consistency models to our current work
synthesizing security exploits
automatically so we started in about
five years ago with a simple goal memory
consistency models have to do with
enforcing the ordering of memory events
in hardware software systems in a well
specified way and we had the goal of
saying for a particular part of the
memory consistency model namely from the
specification given by the ISA to a
particular implementation in Hardware is
that correct
does that pipeline correctly implement
say Intel's total store order memory
model or arms weaker memory model and so
forth we did that based on an axiom
approach that I'll go through in a
little bit of detail after that we
recognize that actually that localized
view at just the microarchitecture
compared to the ISA was insufficient in
many cases because there are so many
other parts of the memory consistency
model landscape in particular high-level
languages have a memory model C
specifies a memory model with Atomics
and it's sequential consistency and so
forth the compiler in the OS play a role
as well because the compiler Maps from
those C constructs down to assembly
language and the OS manages virtual to
physical address translations that also
have a role to play in memory
consistency models and then lastly the
the microarchitecture is sort of
specified as a pipeline is only a piece
of the puzzle because there's the full
coherent memory hierarchy to worry about
and there's also the fact that
eventually this gets mapped down to Vera
log or something like that and we need
to make sure that that too represents a
correct implementation so over the
course of the past five years we've
developed a suite of tools that address
this with this general philosophy being
unified across all of them the basic
approach that we use across all of them
is to have an axiomatic specification
that's given alongside the
implementation and that can be
automatically translated into a set of
happens before graphs and it happens
before graphs have been used by
higher-level compiler and software
people for a while where the nodes in
them are typically instructions or
coarser granularity we are taking those
happens before graphs down to the
microarchitecture and the implementation
level where they map more to Hardware
features the key thing that we're doing
is we're saying if there's an axiom that
says that a must happen before B then we
can draw an edge for it if there's
another axiom that says it B must happen
before C we can draw an edge for it if
there's an axiom that says that C must
happen before a we can draw an edge for
it and in fact we can enumerate this
effectively across all possible
orderings for the software running on a
given Hardware implementation and so
that's why I show sort of multiple
layers of these happens before graphs
the key thing is
if a hums before BV halves for C and C
happens before a and that's a cycle the
saying that a is happening before itself
physically impossible and so every time
we can show that a particular happens
before graph is cyclic we can show that
that is a physically unobservable event
it will not happen and so if there's
something that we're verifying that
should be forbidden it should never
happen we need to ensure that every
possible interleaving every possible
happens to you for graph is cyclic and
so that's that's the secret sauce of all
of these tools up and down the key thing
that's relevant here is to recognize
that the same sorts of event ordering
through memory issues that make a memory
consistency model correct or incorrect
also play intricately in the space of
these kinds of side-channel attacks that
we just heard about because the the
ordering in which you access memory is a
key part of it and so over the past two
years we did this sort of transition
from memory consistency models into the
security space so first I want to tell
you a little bit about these axiomatic
models here's a sort of a simple view of
a dual-core processor five stage
pipeline fetch decode execute kind of
like your architecture class for
undergrad along with some sort of
coherence protocol single write or
multiple reader and so forth we can take
that and we can ask the designer or we
can help automate the process of
expressing that as a set of axioms and
I've shown a very very simple case here
in just two of the axiom so in this case
the top half of this box is an axiom
written in our domain-specific language
called Mew spec that basically says
instructions are fetched in order ok the
second half is for this very simple
processor a very simple axiom that says
if instructions are fetched in order
they will also be executed in order
that's all so this is very simple but we
have actually built up axiomatic
specifications for processors as complex
as Intel Sandy Bridge including the
virtual to physical address translation
issues in which we have parts of the
specification that correspond to
hardware and other parts of the
specification that correspond axioms
that are actually enforced by orderings
done by the operating system and these
axioms can be composed so that the OS is
axioms can be written by an OS
specialist and the hardware axioms can
be written by an a Hardware specialist
and we can put the two together so as I
said we have a process of effectively
exhaustively but we're using SMT solvers
so we aren't sort of stupidly
exhaustively enumerate all possible
interleavings so what you can see there
are a whole bunch of happens before
graphs starting to be enumerated each of
the nodes in one of those columns
corresponds to one stage in a pipeline
this is for a sort of microarchitecture
level consideration so as you go down
one of those columns that's an
instruction going through fetch decode
execute and perhaps some memory
hierarchy stages as well
the different columns in each one of
those boxes the different columns here
correspond to different instructions and
every arrow that's drawn is drawn based
on some axiom that we learned from the
specification nothing is assumed so we
don't assume program order or anything
like that we check everything about the
microarchitecture and so we come up with
this family of micro architectural
happens before graphs and then we use
SMT solver techniques to make it
efficient to check for cyclic or asic
lissa T for each one of these many
happens before graphs as long as we find
a cycle and something was supposed to be
forbidden we're good
if there was something that was supposed
to be forbidden and we find an a cyclic
case we can give that to the designer
and we can say here's your problem and
we have had cases where we give that to
a designer or we look at it ourselves
and we can figure out where the
erroneous a design aspect was that
caused us to be missing an edge that
would have ordered things appropriately
we've also found cases where we were
missing an axiom and had to add an axiom
so we can go either way and the tools
are fast enough to be interactive for
these kinds of specifications the runs
are seconds minutes occasionally hours
not too often hours
so we started as I said from that sort
of is a to microarchitecture view but
clearly real system span from high-level
languages through OS and compilers and
down to microarchitecture and below and
so we wanted a more comprehensive view
and a more recent tool that we started
about three years ago called try check
has this sort of three layer view so we
start from high-level language litmus
tests written in C in the in our case it
could be another language and we take
them through some sort of evaluator that
says what is supposed to be permitted or
forbidden about that litmus test from
the high level language memory models
point of view so we get that permitted
or forbidden output up top we also take
them through compiler mappings that take
from C down to an instruction level view
of things and then across through our
axiomatic models to a microarchitecture
a hardware aware view of what is
observable or unobservable and we put
those two together and you can see the
sort of matrix that results from this if
the software says that something is
supposed to be permitted and our model
says it's observable we're okay if the
software says that something is supposed
to be forbidden and our model says I
have enumerated everything and every
single case is cyclic it will never be
observable also okay and those are the
two green boxes if the software model
says something is supposed to be
permitted and we say it will never be
observed that is overly strict but not a
bug so that's a case where you might be
leaving some performance on the table
but it's okay if the software says that
something is supposed to be forbidden
and we find a case where it's observable
we find an a cyclic happen see for craft
that is a bug and so to test out the
utility of this kind of a framework we
tried it out on a new emerging
instruction set architecture called RISC
five oh I should also say as I said this
is fast enough these are sort of minutes
of execution this is fast enough that
you can iteratively run through design
processes you can decide when you find a
bug what you want to change do you want
to change the is a itself the compiler
or the microarchitecture and we actually
have found bugs basically up and down
the stack we have found bugs
in compilers we have found bugs in
microarchitectures and as I will talk
about now we have found bugs in an
instruction set architecture namely risk
five so for the risk five case study we
started a couple years ago when risk 5s
instruction set architecture this is a
now sort of widely known open-source
instruction set architecture at the time
it was in a draft specification mode but
it was still being widely used and
talked about we took 1,700 different c11
programs as our high-level language
litmus tests and we developed axioms for
seven distinct risk five implementations
so each of these would be a legal
processor within the risk five spec but
different amounts of out-of-order nough
so you can imagine one being a simple in
order single issue processor with no
speculation all the way up to fancy out
of order pipelines with lots of
reordering and speculation they all
abided by the specs though but they
varied in reordering what we found was
when we went through this process
hundreds of times we were ending up in
the Red Square the buggy outcomes Square
and it was true both for the base
specification of the ISA as well as for
one that had additional support for
Atomics that was supposed to actually
help with exactly these kinds of
problems you know providing appropriate
fences and so forth the problem was that
it actually didn't provide appropriate
fences so in the previous talk for
example Christopher talked about
inserting L fences at key points to
order parts of the code risk 5 did not
have a sufficiently what's called
cumulative type offense of that sort to
bring back ordering when it was needed
and in fact it could not legally compile
many C programs as a result of that
because there are C constructs in the C
11 memory model that say that a
programmer is supposed to be able to ask
for sequential consistency and if you
don't have the right kind of fence to
actually implement that ordering you can
never compile that program correctly so
that's one of sort of several
shoes that were found that led to these
kinds of buggy outcome results we worked
to get risk fives attention and
eventually after our paper was published
we did get their attention
and a memory Murano working group was
formed about a year ago to address these
issues and it's really a nice sort of
win-win situation in the sense that the
memory model working group was able to
work through the issues and create a
memory model that's not just sort of
more correct than before but is also
formally specified and a lot cleaner
than before and just last week the
memory model working group and the risk
5 consortium members voted to ratify
this new improvement risk 5 memory model
we're going through the sort of final
sort of dotting the i's and crossing the
t's of making that real that
ratification sort of real so that's
great what about spectrum meltdown so as
I said about a year ago we were making
this mental transition from the sorts of
memory ordering issues that you worry
about for memory consistency models to
the sorts of memory model memory
ordering issues that you worry about for
security and so here's my one slide
simplistic version of what you just
heard a half an hour about Spector in
meltdown are essentially take a
well-known cache side-channel attack in
this case flush and reload mix it with a
widely used Hardware feature speculation
and and what was surprising was not
either of those on their own but sort of
the facility at which new exploits could
be created and so clearly there was an
awful lot of news that broke we had
actually already been working for about
six months at that point on a tool that
would build off of try check and address
some of these issues and so in January
we sort of set to work to sort of
recreate Spector and melt down and see
what else we could find along the way
the basic sort of principled approach
that we wanted was to step away from the
idea of security being kind of closed
the door after the horses out of the
barn to a more principled
forward-looking approach or
could give designers tools that would
help them reason about their systems in
advance and more automatically so you
don't have to stare so much at
individual designs but instead you can
have more automated analysis and our
goal is the following we wanted to be
able to give someone a give a system a
good specification of assistance to
study in a specification of a class of
attack patterns and then from that say
go analyze synthesize tell me what you
find can you find that attack pattern
exploitable in that specified system
that was the idea either output
synthesized attacks or determine that
none are possible now you could say that
this is a malware generator it kind of
is but the goal is to have this be in
the hands of designers rather than in
hands of people who want malware so what
we did is we did that we developed a
tool called checkmate to do this based
on the micro have micro architectural
happens before graphs that I already
talked about and the too long didn't
read version of this is that we the tool
automatically synthesized spectra and
meltdown as well as two new distinct
exploits and many variants and the top
link here is our archive paper from
January where we talk just about the two
new variants and then the bottom link is
the draft hot off the presses of a paper
that will get published in October about
the the actual tool by which we did this
and the texts and techniques by which we
do this that I'm going to talk about
next so in more detail the idea is to
frame these classes of attacks as
patterns of event interleavings but hey
that's what memory consistency models
are already doing that's where it
happens before graphs are already doing
so essentially we're saying here is a
fragment of it happens before graph do
you find it anywhere in an execution and
second of all we want the executions to
be Hardware specific we want to know if
the attack is realizable on a given
Hardware implementation so we need a way
of specifying Hardware and we do that
with the new spec axioms the same as
before so
as before we have the ability to take a
microarchitecture take a
microarchitecture and turn it into
axioms and we have this ability unlike
before to give it a pattern so instead
of saying take the axioms and tell me if
you find a cycle it's take the axioms
and tell me if you find this pattern in
an a cyclic execution so it's a little
bit beyond it's actually a lot beyond
where we were before because it's a
cycle check with a pattern finding in
action as well so for example one of the
things that I don't didn't have time to
talk about in the memory consistency
model space is we have a notion of how
to manage a cache lifetime so whether
when a value comes from a cache line and
where it was sourced from we call those
values in cache lifetimes or vika 'ls
and so we can come up with constructs
that allow us to reason about the
possible sources of a value did it come
from the store buffer or did it come
from the cache and if so was it an
eviction out of the cache in between and
so forth so we have fickle creates the
correspond to something new in the cache
and vehicle expires that corresponds to
something being evicted out of the cache
so you take your micro architectural
axioms you take a pattern that you're
looking for and you take some
constraints on the number of cores the
number of threads the number of
instructions to keep things tractable
and you send that into our tool
checkmate again it enumerates possible
execution graphs that a are a cyclic and
that be show this pattern and now I
think you can see that this is a case
where automation is a huge sort of brain
helper you would hate to have to sort of
stare at complicated graphs and look for
that pattern in them you want some help
with this so the specification is
essentially the same as before
speculation is something that music is
already supported basically we can allow
for items to be brought into the cache
in a way that isn't necessarily ordered
with instruction execution right and we
can allow for items to be brought into
the cache
in a way that isn't particularly ordered
with branch instructions so those are
the kinds of things that actually were
raised in the previous talk in addition
because we have this full stack analysis
we can handle software user level
software operating system and hardware
events and locations user level software
operating system and hardware ordering
details harder optimizations like
speculation fit in well because we've
handled operating systems in the past in
a tool called code check we can handle
processes and resource sharing and
memory hierarchies and cache coherence
protocols I don't want to oversell this
we are not going down to Vera login this
tool although we do in other tools but
we do think that once you're operating
in this axiomatic landscape this is a
huge help in automating the analysis so
the last piece of this puzzle is how do
we do these sort of pattern enumerations
and that's with relational model finding
so in the first half of the talk we did
the cycle analysis using SMT techniques
this is relational model finding because
we need to find a pattern not just a
cycle and so RMF essentially tries to
find these satisfying instances or sub
parts within a larger graph in this case
we're doing this by taking the new spec
translating it into alloy which is a
domain-specific language that's intended
to fit into a relational model finding
approach the RMF problems get mapped
onto a model finder called kodkod which
in turn uses off-the-shelf Sat solvers
so in this way we can feed together and
automate the process and so here is what
Spector looks like in our world so as
before these columns of nodes correspond
to instructions being executed you can
see by the label on the top the the
different threads that are involved you
can see for example the spectrum was
based on a flush and reload threat
pattern so in the upper right that's the
pattern that the relational model
finding technique is looking for you can
see that you would not want to analyze
that graph to look for that pattern in
but it's in there follow the red arrows
and you can find it and the last thing
that it does is it generates the
skeleton or the litmus test the security
that must test that would correspond to
a version of Spectre this is a template
for code you still have to sort of make
it concrete with particular addresses
and so forth but the step from here to a
real piece of Spectre code is a pretty
straightforward piece of programming
work for someone who's familiar with the
instruction set that they're operating
in okay so that's Spectre one of the
things that we wanted to do was sit and
what's a Spectre was based on one class
of exploits called a flush and reload
threat pattern we wanted to see what
about other threat patterns prime and
probe being one that has been talked
about a lot in the literature and so we
said what if we put in this different
pattern the prime and probe pattern in
what happens then and in fact what
happened then was that we found two
distinct variants of the exploit in this
case using invalidation patterns between
two cores rather than flush and reload
patterns on a single core to create a
new case of almost identical to Spectre
but within validations being the way
that things were evicted out of the
cache rather than flushes on a single
core and again the tool generates the
security litmus test automatically we
call them security litmus tests rather
than malware because the idea is that
just as in memory consistency models we
have built up as a community a suite of
tests over time the designers use to
stress test their systems we view the
ability to generate security litmus
tests as an important construct for
designers to help them design against
these sorts of threats and to explore
new classes of threats so one of the
things that we want to do in subsequent
work is to automatically generate the
threat patterns that might be most
interesting that's actually where we are
right now okay so second last slide
this is the money shot in some way so
the top part of this table are the flush
and reload patterns the bottom part of
this table or prime and probe it's the
exploit pattern the number of
instructions that we placed as a bound
in the relational model finding because
that does affect the execution time of
all these tools but what you can see is
that with relatively small instruction
counts you can generate pretty real
exploits such as Spector meltdown and
the new variants the minutes to
synthesize the first exploit that is
this thing is relational model finding
and finding exploit you know the first
one is sort of five minutes to a couple
hours and it continues to run until it
has found all the possible exploits all
the possible ways that that pattern can
be found in all the possible graphs that
could be enumerated and that's sort of
seven minutes to three or four hours the
number of synthesis exploit that were
synthesized correspond to all the
different balletic ways that you can
create something that's Spector like or
respect or Prime like and you can see
that those numbers get quite high and so
one of the values that we see in this
work is the ability to give someone the
reassurance that they found not just oh
wait but someone could exploit their
code but hopefully a whole bunch of ways
that someone could exploit their
hardware so in terms of takeaways yes we
found two two new variants Spector Prime
and meltdown prime that use cache and
validations rather than C flush but more
importantly to us is this key overall
philosophy that the event ordering
issues of security exploit patterns
align strongly with the memory
consistency model analysis that we've
already been doing it's a very
principled step from ad hoc one-off
analysis of different exploits to formal
automated synthesis and the goal has
always been to span software operating
system and hardware for a holistic but
Hardware aware analysis and those are
the two papers that I'm inviting you to
read and if you remember nothing else
please wake up and look at the two names
in red because everyone in the room
should want to hire these two wonderful
students Caroline triple sat down after
our last try check paper and said I want
to work on security and within six
months she was doing this she is an
amazing PhD student who will be on the
markets this year yeah Tina and Eric are
also did a lot of the work that I talked
about today including finding through
our toolset errors and to formally prove
incorrect proven correct compiler
mapping proofs and errors in compiles
that go with it and some other universal
memory consistency model analysis beyond
witness tests that I didn't have time to
talk about so with that I'm happy to
answer some questions Thanks
[Applause]
that was a really interesting tour thank
you um so one question they do have is
you talk about having these specific
micro architectural happens before
graphs and once you've got one of those
you can go search for it and synthesize
a whole bunch of examples and this was a
natural follow-up question which is you
know if you look at something like the
net specter attack that discussed a side
channel based on the power state of the
avx2 units or if you look at variant
fours those are about memory dependent
speculation so there's this natural sort
of question of can you take what you've
got here and you know actually go and
find these new classes or is it
something where you do need to know all
these you hp's up front and then once
you've got them you can go find them so
we have as I said we have found bugs
that span OS 2 hardware we have found
bugs that that span between cores so one
thing I want to stress is the we aren't
doing this per graph we are doing this
for a set of axioms so as long as one
can write the axioms we can enumerate
the graphs so that's one thing the
second thing is the things like memory
dependence they're already within our
model so yes net specter I am pretty
sure we could write axioms to handle
sort of how the packet processing feeds
through the rest of the system clarify
my question I mean you you synthesize
primum probe or you synthesize the specs
probably melt that priming things like
this right and there's like essentially
either this tool should have spat out
that you could have memory dependence
based speculation bugs or it didn't and
like either way is interesting so so for
example as far as I know net specter is
still flush and reload it's just a
different style of flush and reload the
tool that that causes the invocation to
happen differently I'm not we can take
this offline all right let me finish
okay so if it's within flush and reload
then with the right axioms we can
synthesize it I agree and I said at the
end that we do want to be able to
enumerate new classes of exploits and
that's what we're working on
yeah Stefan so so based on your
experience with checkmate do you have
any advice for hardware designers for
how to design their cpu so that
checkmate won't find any exploits when
we started this work five years ago
people I think we're very reluctant at
the idea of having to have axiomatic
specifications alongside their design
and I'm hoping that over the set of
observations that we've made over these
five years we're increasingly finding
designers more open to having that be a
key part of the design process so one
analogy I make is 20 years ago
architects didn't think about power they
were encouraged not to think about power
that was for later in the design chain
today I'm sad to say that I would say
verification is still if you if I say
the word verification people think about
something is very late in the hardware
design process and one of our goals is
to make tools that are amenable to being
used earlier in the design process so
that hardware designers will be more
open to using them because they'll be an
interactive speed so we think that the
axiomatic approach while not natural to
today's architects is helpful enough
that people should be coming around to
it and I you know we can talk about
whether to do sort of a correct by
construction flow where the axioms sort
of follow sort of automatically from
synthesis tools or whether the axioms
are written alongside a traditional
design I'm ok with either one the main
thing is I think we need these interface
specifications that let us say at this
point here are some rules you should be
able to count on and I think that's key
if we start to have these interface
specifications with corresponding axioms
then we can automate different analysis
techniques some of which would be sort
of synthesis synthesis driven or correct
by construction and some of which would
be
the ancillary but still sort of formal
documentation one of the key things is
most memory consistency models for
example are still written in English but
increasingly people are coming around to
the idea that they should be written in
a way that can be sort of automatically
analyzed and verified and so
increasingly so for example risk five
went from not very correct and written
in English spec to now being something
that is formally specified there's a
there are formal models for it and I
think that's a good sign okay let you go
back to five years ago where we don't
know how to exploit speculative
execution do you think your methodology
can identify any kind of exploit
variants that we know right now so I'm
not gonna say that there's a there's a
chicken-and-egg aspect of this of
modeling enough to be able to find the
things we were finding bugs before
Spectre in meltdown broke and we found
different bugs after the news broke we
hadn't been using speculation in all of
our models before January and so we
added it in afterwards there could be
something that we are choosing to
abstract away now that we should include
in a model going forward but the basics
of spectra in meltdown have been known
for a while like speculation and flush
and reload are both concepts that have
been known for more than five years so
in that sense people should have known
but I think people were unaware of the
facility with which they could be
exploited it seems that there is some
area that we can we couldn't identify
the problem by using newer methodology
looks very fun most and very nice do you
have any idea that what you can provide
through this method in general and
I think they couldn't provide so at the
end of the day we're gonna see it on
another type of side channel probably
completely different variant from the
speculative execution but we couldn't
tell whether they're actually such a
things you can just are using your
methodology right so as I've said we are
looking at ways to automatically
generate the new attack pattern classes
so that we can for example you can
imagine genetic algorithms or something
but that creates new graph snippets and
then says is this an attack class or not
so it's an ongoing thing but the ability
to automatically and now analyze once
you have an attack class seems like an
important step forward my question a
great talk I really enjoyed your talk my
question is a variant only for I'm
asking the same question or not actually
in but so you mentioned sort of the two
side channel attacks you my sunnies are
based on memory caches right so these
are priming probe and the prime Russian
ruler Russian leader on there are a lot
of caches in the architecture not just
that and the question is how much work
how minimal is your technique to
actually sort of fun you know we apply
these things to other to other caches in
in the CPU or elsewhere I get the
feeling I mean we would I think everyone
in the room would like it if if there
was sort of one big answer there clearly
isn't it's it steps on the way I feel
that we have all been we've all been
lied to you about what architectural
state is let's be honest right so when I
teach an undergrad architecture class we
talk about architectural state being
what the sufferer can see but that is an
extremely nebulous thing so for example
Christopher's talk talked about timing
jitter that's because there's a form of
observability that comes from what you
can't
one of the things that we're working on
right now is ways to take these crafts
and put quantifiers onto the edges to
say this is an exploit if the timing
sequence is sufficiently observable and
that has to do with the timing analysis
granularity against the performance
variations but you could you could just
as we could imagine an observer model
that puts edge weights based on time you
could put edge weights based on power
dissipation on radio emanations on
temperature right and say that if
someone's in the room and could measure
temperature variations across the chip
then this becomes a side channel that we
need to worry about so there are ways to
add quantifiers to some of this that
seem promising mmm but I'm not we're not
done with that yet for shortly hired
Caroline and your teen and see what
happens okay so in some sense that's my
question is like is this is this work at
the level of we need you know you mean
the Caroline in the room to actually do
this or sort of more engineers that can
actually use this tool to sort of the
goal is to help them be engineers we
gave a tutorial a disco about a year and
a half ago our materials are online the
tools checkmate is an open sourced yet
but the try check and pipe check and so
forth those tools are all open sourced
the DSL is available I'll be honest it's
still kind of a pair programming
experience probably at its best right
you know you sitting alongside someone
who knows what's what but the goal is to
have it be something that a hardware
designer can use on their own yeah great
all right let's thank the speaker thank
you
[Applause]
okay our next talk is going to be given
by owner mu and owner is a professor of
computer science at ETH Zurich and he's
also on the faculty at Carnegie Mellon
University owners broad research
interests are in computer architecture
systems and bioinformatics and a major
current focus of his is on memory and
storage systems and he's going to talk
today about memory systems so we're
gonna be changing a little bit from
meltdown inspector to row him/her and
beyond owner has a history with us at
Microsoft Research in fact he was the
first member of the computer
architecture group at Microsoft Research
back in 2006 and owner has won numerous
awards and I'll just mention one here he
was the winner of the inaugural I Triple
E computer scientist aasaiya T young
computer architect award so take it away
owner thank you thank you thank you very
much Alec is this working
okay yeah it's great to be back here at
Microsoft as always and thanks for the
invitation Stefan and I like I'll talk
about draw hammer I actually see that
it's going to be a change compared to
the previous things but I actually see
these as related because it's about the
mindset that hardware is not as
vulnerable and you can actually attack
things and I think there's a history if
you had time that we could go over of
these Hardware related attacks
I think meltdown inspector happened
because some some things like rope
hammer for example instigated some
people to actually examine issues in
hardware and they actually found out
other issues in hardware we can talk
about that separately but before let me
see this is not working oh okay
okay so before I go into Rohan basically
we're going to talk about the main
memory system it's a critical component
of all systems that we designed today
whatever you're designing you gotta have
some working storage and this system
must scale in many dimensions in terms
of size technology efficiency costs
algorithms we used to manage it etc to
maintain the performance growth and the
scaling benefits that we've been used to
so far and regardless of whatever you're
attached to main memory your bottleneck
by that interface the main memory I'll
very quickly go over some trends that
are affecting main memory to set the
stage and how we came to a row hammer
basically these are three major trends
that are affecting main memory as I see
them we want more capacity more
bandwidth more quality of service more
performance this was I think evidence in
Marcos nose keynote with the Beast and
the mega beast engines that had
terabytes and terabytes of memory
actually energy and power is the key
system design concern and technology
scaling is ending this talks about we're
going to be about technology scaling but
to understand that I think we need to
covers the other trends also we are put
we're able to put a lot of course on
machines and applications are becoming
increasing data intensive and we want to
consolidate more and more that's driving
the capacity bandwidth and quality of
service requirements up and up
performance requirements this is one
example this was actually from a paper
by HP Labs in University of Michigan
they've shown that core count is
increasing much faster than DRAM
capacity and that's why we're ball
nicked by DM capacity you could argue
with all of the numbers on this graph
and you could say that all this trend is
not continuing but if you think about
why the trend may not be continuing we
may not be able to feed the course with
the data they need so we actually may
not be placing course as fast as much as
we were doing in the past but the trends
actually increasing is similar to this
in GPUs anyway where we want more
capacity from memory and that drives the
capacity of the DRAM chip and let's take
a look at the history of the Year I'm in
the last 18 years in terms of how much
capacity bandwidth and latency has
improved this has been always a capacity
focused business and if you look at this
capacity is improved by more than
hundred x in the last 18 years and you
can see that in the last few years the
trend is not exponential it's actual
staggering elements so we're having
difficulties in the year I'm scaling
this is an evidence of that I'll give
you more evidence in this talk bandwidth
has not improved as much but you could
potentially improve it but what do you
think of latency how much has it
improved in the last 18 years this much
yeah I agree it's this much in this
graph it's basically 30 percent income
are dear if you want to pay for it you
can except of course give your arm and
leg and you can pay for it but latency
is almost constant but DRM is critical
for performance capacity latency
bandwidth different applications have
different requirements I think these are
backward-looking applications we have
many many more forward-looking
applications that are going to put even
more pressure on the Iran okay
the second major trend energy is a key
system design concern and memory
consumes a lot of the energy this is a
paper from IBM in 2003 where they shown
that in in their big iron servers 40 to
50 percent of the entire system energy
spent on the off chip memory hierarchy
and fast forward to today there are
reports from IBM again in power ate more
than 40% of the power is spent just
solely in DRM that's true for GPUs also
that other paper for Miska 2015 is from
GPUs and our results will actually show
of that also so memory energy is
becoming a big concern and one of the
issues is DM consumes power when it's
not used you need to periodically
refresh it and this turns out to be a
scaling problem also which we may get to
toward the end of the talk so on top of
all of this we're requiring a lot more
from memory going forward we're going to
require even more with the new
applications but on top of this we're
having difficulties with the arm
technology scaling basically we relied
on reducing the size of the DM cell to
increase the capacity but this is ending
basically ITRs has been projecting for a
long time that DM will not scale below X
nanometers and I like keeping X over
here because I don't need to change my
slides but they change their projections
of course I'll give you the number for X
in the next slide but scaling has
enabled us to get more capacity
reasonable energy scaling lower costs it
didn't help us with latency that much
but it does it did help with other
things so what is the scaling problem
that we're having with DM so it for any
memory to work you need to have an a
storage device India and the storage
devices the capacitor anytime an access
device in the year and the access device
the access transistor the bitline
this enzyme fire both of these
components need to work reliably for any
memory to work in D Ram this capacitor
must be large enough for reliable
sensing and this access transistor and
the sensing structures must be large
enough for low leakage and high high
retention time and this was the value
that was assigned text by ITRs in 2013
they basically said scaling below 35
nanometers is challenging what do you
think what do you guys think where we
are at memory feature size today is it
35 nanometers this is the dimensions of
the cell 10 any guesses 1z that's good
yes we're about maybe 17 nanometers or
so clearly we've gone below 35
nanometers but we have had issues so
basically the app scaling has become
increasingly difficult and we're going
to talk about one of the big problems in
the year I'm scaling so what have people
done about it basically this has led to
the proliferation of different types of
DM both the application requirements and
the requirements from the bottom as
there is out there many emerging
technologies you can see that there's 3d
stack DRM you get higher bandwidth
reduce latency DRM low power DRM
non-volatile memory
they all have greens but they all have
Reds also so there's no single memory
that's good at anything as a result one
major trend has been going into hybrid
memory technologies where you have
multiple different technologies
potentially multiple different DRMs and
you design the hardware and the software
to manage data allocation and movements
such that you achieve the greens as much
as possible while avoiding the Reds as
much as possible and this requires
clearly changes to the interface and
changes to become more intelligent in
terms of how we manage memory but this
doesn't change the fact that we need to
have memory in the system and the memory
needs to scale and this is one way of
trying to scale memory but it turns out
it's very difficult to get rid of DRAM
from the system people have looked at
using MRAM for example or PCM patient
memory but it's going to be very
difficult to get rid of all of the DM
from the system ok so let's talk let's
go a little bit more into detail in the
memory scaling problem there's a lot in
the memory problem memory space and
we're working on a lot but I'll start
with the security part of it or
reliability and safety I see these as
interconnected and I'm going to make you
make the connection but there's a lot
more to do
the memory area as you can see so why
start with security I like tying this to
human lives also how many people here
know about Abraham Maslow that's great
yeah he was a very famous American
psychologist he dedicated his life to
understanding why people do things they
do as a result he basically this is his
major work that book that he iterated
over during his lifetime and he's
probably more famous for this one
essentially which is Maslow's hierarchy
of needs and he basically said that we
need to start with a reliability and
security because if you're not reliable
and secure you cannot think about
relationships friends and you definitely
don't care about higher levels of Arts
if you're about to die at this moment
right so that's why we need to start
with relapse and secured and this is
another thing that I use actually in my
classes probably this should be familiar
with people who are living in the
Washington State yeah this is the Tacoma
Narrows Bridge that doesn't exist
anymore this was built in 1940 and six
months later it collapsed this way
because of air static flutter and the
new bridges are actually double bridges
it's not it was actually put put in
there for bandwidth reasons but it's
good for reliability also having two
bridges over there and I I actually
think about asking while I was at
Microsoft Research I interacted with a
lot of security people and this
definition of security I like a lot it's
really about preventing unforeseen
consequences and I see the previous talk
and the previous two talks actually
thinking about potentially unforeseen
consequences and how can we prevent them
let me tie back into the DM scaling
problem this this is a slide I showed
earlier basically we're having
difficulties with reducing the size of
the circuit as we reduce the size of the
circuit both of the reliability
properties you may are difficult to
maintain essentially this capacitor
becomes unreliable it becomes more
vulnerable to noise and this access
transistor becomes more leaky and more
vulnerable to noise as a result it's
really difficult to reduce the size of
the circuit and we've been doing a lot
of studies both at the large scale I'll
give you one example the large-scale
study we've essentially analyzed in this
paper from 2015 all of the memory years
that Facebook has recorded over the
course of a year in their entire server
fleet this is a lot of servers actually
and this is a correlational study as you
can see it
as chip density increases the server
failure rate increases this is because
of memory errors not not due to other
areas so there's a clear correlation
between higher capacity and higher
higher errors and there's a lot more
data in this paper if you're interested
which I'm not going to cover and when we
start first start studying the DM
scaling problem we also wanted to do the
small scale studies and we built this
infrastructure which is essentially an
FPGA based memory controller where we
could do a lot of tests using this
memory controller we could configure
anything we wanted and we keep improving
this and we wanted to study first
retention issues but we discovered the
Rope hammer problem by building this
infrastructure where we discovered the
Rope Hammer problem you could do many
many tests in parallel with different
FPGAs and we open sources infrastructure
so if you're interested you can download
it it's C++ programmable now it's much
more programmer friendly and you can do
the studies on the FPGA s we don't
provide the FPGAs you that you got to
buy so with this kind of instructor you
can actually do a lot of studies on real
DRAM chips we've studied DM retention
I'm not going to talk about this is
really really interesting and this is
really the fundamental scaling issue at
DM as you reduce the size of the circuit
data becomes very difficult to maintain
inside a cell so charge escapes and
charge leaks how do you figure out how
long the charge will stay in that so
that you can determine your refresh rate
we'll get back to that if we have time
but while we were actually doing studies
in this infrastructure we were inspired
by other studies that we were doing in
flash memory and flash memory is very
much prone to read disturb errors and we
said oh maybe there are we disturbing
indium also let's test it using this
infrastructure and what we found was
actually curious at that time we said we
basically found that you can predictably
induce memory errors bit flips in most
DRAM memory chips at the time this is
called the Dro hammer problem it's
essentially a simple hardware failure
mechanism that can create a widespread
system security vulnerability and you
can do it in a programmatic way and
people wrote things like this this is
one of the examples I like this I put it
over here because I like the title it
says forget software now hackers are
exploiting physics and this actually I
think explains the problem in a nice way
so what is the problem if you look at
the
it consists of a bunch of rows and if
you want to read data from a row you
need to activate that row which means
that you need to apply high voltage to
that word line and if you want to reach
some other row you need to deactivate
that row or if this is called the
pre-charge in the apply low voltage now
if you keep doing this repeatedly
activate pre-charge activate pre charge
activate pre charge activate pre charge
before the cells get refreshed and if
you do it enough times it turns out in
most modern new um ships adjacent rows
get bit flips some bits flip from 1 to 0
or 0 to 1 depending on the encoding now
that's not supposed to happen clearly
because you're not even writing to
memory you're not you're reading from
memory and you're affecting the cells
that are around you those cells could be
belonging to some other application to
the operating system essentially this I
reliability problem but this could also
be a security vulnerability so we call
this the hammer Grove
we call these victim rolls and it turns
out that most real DRAM chips that you
combine the market more than 80% of them
at the time you've done these tests were
vulnerable we could predictably induce
these errors and this is actually a
scaling problem because this didn't
happen before 2010 the first instance
that we saw was in 2010 and all of the
chips that were manufactured between
2012 and 2013 that we tested were
actually vulnerable why is the scaling
problem essentially cells got too close
to each other they're not elect enough
isolated electrically from each other
and one I'll talk about the causes very
briefly later on but one intuitive
causes essentially electromagnetic
coupling because one word lined is too
close to the other word line whenever
you toggle this word line apply high
voltage the other word line is not
electrically isolated enough you're
toggling it a little bit as a result
you're opening that word line which
means that the cells that are vulnerable
to this effect are leaking a little bit
if you do it enough times they leak a
little bit enough times and if you do it
enough times before the cells get
refreshed
you basically depleted the charge on
some of the cells over there if the
cells weren't too close to each other
meaning back in 2008 you didn't have
this problem and this is a very
fundamental problem in any kind of
memory actually any kind of memory when
it scales you get the sort of read
disturbance issues if you have time
we'll talk about flash memory but we
won't have time for that
so what's more interesting about
this being in dear I'm as DM is directly
exposed to the programming language this
is one example programming language
assembly language so we wrote this code
which is essentially executed the user
level what it does is it basically
avoids cache it's for these two
addresses avoid row hits for those two
addresses and it basically ping pongs
activates to xmi to the same bank and if
the chip is vulnerable it'll essentially
get these errors and you can download
this quote and run it on your laptop
actually you can you can download
google's code which which improved our
code and they you could you're more
likely to discover bit flips and at the
time we did these studies this was
around 2012 basically we ran it on real
systems and you can see that as long as
you have a memory controller that's good
at activating fasts that's fat that it
is able to access memory fast you're
able to induce these errors and there's
nothing special about intel and AMD all
of the memory controllers that are out
in the market are capable of doing that
in in real processors today so it's a
real reliability and security issue
in fact it's we thought it was more of a
security issue than reliability issue
when we wrote the paper the first
sentence we said we used was memory
isolation is a key property of a
reliable and secure computing system and
access to one memory idea should not
have unintended side effects on data
stored in other addresses I still
believe this I think this is very
fundamental we should keep this
invariant and we also said that you
could actually design an attack that
could take over an entire system by
exploiting submit flips and the good
folks at Google project zero did exactly
that they published this beautiful blog
post it's beautiful system security
engineering where they said they exploit
the Dro of hammer bug I don't like the
term bug I think a failure mechanism is
a nicer one over here to gain kernel
privileges and this is directly copied
and pasted from their blog posts from
2015 babies detest the selection of
laptops and copy this found a subset of
them makes a bit the problem and they
they build to working politically and
exploits one of them is less interesting
to me it attacks the Google native
client the other one essentially is able
to run a user level process and it's
able to induce these bit flips and they
were able to induce bit flips in the
page table entries of that user level
process that point to their own page
table and if you're able to actually do
that now you can chain
the contents of your own page table for
example you can you can gain right and
evil access to your own page table and
once you have that access you have
entire you have full access to the
entire memory that's essentially what
they did and they were able to do this
successfully on I believe 50% of the
machines that they have tested laptops
and this became even more interesting at
that time the skull to row hammer while
near volte and people's stores start
drawing pictures like this I like
analogies and this is a beautiful
analogy that someone had on Twitter it's
like breaking into an apartment by
repeatedly slamming neighbor's door
until the vibrations open the door that
you were really after so if you want to
escape from here you might want to start
banging on these walls over here okay
and there's a lot a lot of attacks that
were developed on top of this I'm not
going to go over this this is basically
these slides are available you can go
over these people have developed a lot
of attacks over the years even very
recently I'm gonna highlight a couple of
them this is one of the attacks from tu
grass the sector the same folks who
develop meltdown inspector later on they
basically show that you could remotely
gain access to the system of a website
visitor by exploiting by inducing row
hammer induced bit flips through
JavaScript very interesting this is
another one this basically showed that
you could do this on an Android system
in an ARM processor and what they did
was they were able to because they knew
how the operating system actually
allocated pages they were able to figure
out which pages are vulnerable to row
hammer through a profiling process and
they were able to fool the operating
system into allocating a page table into
a page that they knew was vulnerable to
row hammer and they would hammer that
and they would gain access
deterministically to many many cell
phones this way that's another beautiful
paper actually and you can download
their app I think I don't know if this
is still functional if you would like to
be hacked and these are actually more
recent this is May 2018 the same the
same folks at Amsterdam they basically
show that you could do this through the
GPU in an integrated again in a mobile
system and a GPU is much more because it
can access memory much faster you can
actually induce these bit flips a much
better and you could actually do it over
the network also
through the RDMA by exploiting RDMA and
I believe there's more to come maybe one
solution to your old hammer is this it's
another attack that that could drive
people crazy I don't think this is a
good solution let me very quickly go
over understanding go hammer and then
we'll talk about solutions and then
maybe some future vulnerabilities so as
I said they're a bunch of causes the
secretary complex problem as circuit
becomes smaller
you have many failure mechanisms that
affect this that in combination lead to
row hammer I'm not going to go into this
in detail but manufacturers are very
well aware of it and we're in touch with
them and if you have this sort of
infrastructure you can do many many
studies and I'm going to talk about a
couple of these basically the what is
the difference between the address of a
row that you're hammering and the victim
Rose we did this study and it turns out
most of them are adjacent rows as
expected but some of them are not
adjacent because there's some internal
remapping that DM address remapping that
DMM does internally so if you want to
hammer really perfectly you may want to
know this address mapping or if you want
to protect the access interval today you
can access memory every 55 nanoseconds
that's the TRC role cycling delay that's
a single bank if you actually prohibit
this you can get rid of the heirs
clearly this is one solution you can
throttle the accesses to memory by
reducing the access rate so this is
clear you can do that this is not a good
solution I believe because this reduces
your performance clearly refresh
interval is another parameter that you
can play with clearly if you refresh the
UM more often the probability of attack
reduces this is you reduce the refresh
is by 7x it gets rid of every single
error that we see in the DEA but 7x
increasing the refresh refresh is by 7x
is probably not a good solution even
though it solves the problem this is
very interesting because the attack is
actually much more possible if your data
pattern is it conducive to the attack so
if your data pad is solid like this you
don't get a lot of errors but if your
data pattern is this way which induces
much more coupling between the different
cells that are adjacent to each other
you get many many more errors okay so
there are a bunch of other results I'm
not going to go through this the red
ones are the important ones for security
errors are repeatable if you can
actually flip a bit you're going to flip
it again and again and again and again
and you can actually get Meniere's per
cache line which means that simple error
correcting codes are not able to get rid
of all of the errors you need more
sophisticated error correcting codes and
cells are actually affected by to
aggressor rows on either side this is
actually what Google exploited to make
the attack much more powerful they
basically did this double-sided row
hammering and they hammered a single row
by sandwiching it between two two things
that are hammered there's a lot more in
hammer analysis in this paper and a
recent paper that I've written I'd be
happy to talk about that separately also
but let's talk about solutions element
these are more traditional solutions I
think which all have downsides clearly
you can make better DRAM chips but
that's going to be difficult to do you
can refresh frequently well get back to
that you can have sophisticated ECC and
you can have access contests to throttle
but all of these actually come with
downsides I believe so we want to have
simple solutions to the problem and our
paper actually looks at all of these
different solutions let me tell you
about what is employed in existing
systems because in existing systems you
have to employ something to be able to
catch it and this is apple's patch for
row hammer basically they said that they
mitigated their own hammer issue by
increasing the memory refresh rates and
this is I think employed by industry
this is this is the configurability that
we have in our memory controllers today
we can do it and as a result we do it
and I believe this is a reasonable
solution this is much simpler than the
software based solutions that could
potentially detect the attacks of course
there's downside is we actually don't
want to increase the refresh rates in
real systems we want to get rid of
refresh as much as possible if you
increase the refresh rates you're
increasing the performance impact and
also power impact so our solution was a
more probabilistic we call that the
probabilistic adjacent Rove activation
the ideas after you close a row you
activate one of the neighbors or both of
the neighbors with very low probability
and this gives you a reliable to
guarantee that's better than they
reliable to guarantee that you have for
hard disks for today so this is pretty
strong depending depends on of course
how you set your key probability over
here but the big advantage of this is
you don't refresh the entire memory you
refresh only in a targeted way and very
very infrequently as a result the
overheads are very low and it's also
stateless you don't need to keep track
of any
state to be able to do that because you
know which are your closing before you
refresh it probabilistically so there
are multiple ways of actually
implementing it the first one is
actually employed in the yam chips going
forward I'm not sure if this is a really
really good idea inside the DM chip
going forward fully because the way it's
employed in existing DRAM chips without
changing the interface is by exploiting
the slack and timing parameters whenever
you close or all there is enough slack
in the timing parameters that the DI
manufacturers can sneak in a refresh to
the adjacent grows for one of the
adjacent rows so we're actually shown
that there's plenty of slack today that
you can exploit to be able to do this
reliably but going forward you actually
want to remove that slack also so that
we can make deer and lower latency so I
don't believe this is a really good
solution without changing the interface
the second solution is doing it in the
memory controller having a more
intelligent memory controller that
basically knows which rows are
physically adjacent to each other this
information is not known to the memory
controller today because DM actually
does remapping of ROS internally for
various reasons but if this information
is communicated to the memory controller
I believe there could be much better
solutions so we need a better DM
interface and more intelligent memory
controllers to solve these problems in a
in a nice way I think so this was
actually actually something that I
recently saw apparently this is one of
the thing Pat's in the BIOS you can have
different ro hammer solutions you could
either double your refresh rate or have
this hardware ro hammer protection which
is kind of mysterious but clearly
they're doing some probabilistic
solution so you can actually change the
row hammer activation probability in
some way to be - you can decide your
protection level if you will over here
it was fun to see this okay
so industry is actually writing papers
about it - this is not related to neural
hammer but this talks about the deer I'm
scaling challenges in general and it
focused on what I said is real is the
real scaling challenge the refresh
problem I and the variable retention
time problem which we will cover if you
have time still but the the key point
that I want to make is other than
recommending this paper that was written
by two unlikely partners that will ever
write a paper together Samsung and Intel
they also say a good solution for them
is actually quark taking DM and
controllers together and having
intelligent controller this paper
actually proposed error-correcting
quotes to be inside the diagram if you
went to the DI manufacturers ten years
ago and said I want their correcting
codes in your chip you would be kicked
out of the door as soon as possible
probably because they don't want to
reduce their capacity but now actually
DRAM chips going forward will have error
correcting codes but as I said error
correcting quotes are good at solving
random issues there they're actually a
costly solution you want to really
target the solutions to the problems at
hand so I think row hammer can be sold
in a much easier way than error
correcting codes the reason they're
putting error correcting codes is
because of retention because they do not
they're not able to determine the
retention times really easily and as a
result air quaking quotes can correct
some of those areas that are happening
because of retention issues okay so so
in I said intelligent memory controls is
one solution and we know actually how to
build this we've actually been building
this for flash memory for a long time I
believe GM is going to look increasingly
more like flash memory as it scales down
and flash memory if you look at the
flash memory controller it's a paper
that we recently written based on about
eight years of research that we've done
in the field there's a lot of error
correction mechanism that goes into the
memory controller memory controller
really understands the different types
of errors and actually targets the error
correction mechanisms to the different
types of errors specializes it's
mechanisms and I'd be happy to talk
about that in more detail
certainly so basically key takeaway I
think to solve these issues going
forward is we want intelligent memory
controllers and clearly we have a
challenge and opportunity going forward
how do we design fundamentally secure
reliable and safe computing
architectures okay how much time do we
have
okay any any questions so far you said
you wanted this to be interactive so I
can take some questions and then maybe I
can continue told us about some hardware
mitigations for for these kinds of
problems is it conceivable that there
would be some simple conservative
characterization of software that would
would prove that even the the old style
of hardware would avoid wrote have more
problems maybe your compiler would then
make an effort to meet these conditions
about software so you're thinking of
basically somehow analyzing the software
and saying you're I think it's certainly
possible you could potentially analyze
these cases I'm not sure if it's really
worth the effort because usually this is
you're probably thinking of this being a
reliability problem in a real production
environment right not as a security
problem both for a security problem I
guess you could you then you have to
analyze all of the code that runs on
your system right you need to be in a
protected environment and you disallow
quote or maybe you change the code
dynamically if it does zero hammer I
think it's certainly possible yes I
believe it's a higher overhead solution
because I think hardware this is really
a solution that can be the problem that
can be fixed relatively easily in
hardware that's my belief okay
but people have actually proposed a
performance counter based mechanisms not
necessarily a static and/or program
analysis mechanisms that try to figure
out whether a program is real hammering
but people have looked at performance
counters and try to figure out oh is
this code doing hammering but there's
performance overhead clearly associated
with those Thanks sure yes
great corner I have always wondered what
was the hypothesis that led you guys to
discover row hammer right so and maybe
there are lessons there to discover more
vulnerabilities yeah yeah remember no no
that's great that's a great question I
think well basically I'll say the
hypothesis was this infrastructure that
we built for flash memory so we've built
this infrastructure for flash memory and
earlier than we did for VM and we knew
that there are a lot of errors clearly
disturb errors are actually a clear
problem with flash memory and control is
actually taken to cantos and we want to
say we knew that to read the
strawberries are actually problem in
other memory technologies also SRAM for
example and we want to test though it
could potentially happen in DM if it
scales down it so I think this is the
value of the infrastructure I must say
if you didn't have this flash memory
infrastructure maybe we wouldn't be
building the DM infrastructure also okay
one more what do you think about Intel's
hardware medication called TR our target
low differ target refreshed or whatever
yeah I think we can have a longer
conversation relates that I believe I
believe a probabilistic solution is much
simpler just to clarify in your opinion
the research community has proposed
simpler and more effective solution than
what the what the hardware whether Intel
or the DRAM vendors have decided to
adopt so no not not exactly I think
targeted refreshed changes the interface
a little bit without exposing the DRAM
internal so I think I believe if you can
if you get rid of the interchange the
interface a little bit differently
exposing the gem internals you can have
a much better solution so it does a
different trade off basically they don't
want to they don't want to expose the DM
internals to the memory control I
believe that's why they went to the
target or refresh solution but I think
if we relaxed the interface a little bit
which we have many many other reasons
for doing so for example if you want to
enable in-memory computation if you want
to enable lower latency it's good to get
rid of some of the
change the interface a little bit then I
think you can go into other solution the
other answer to your question di
manufacturers are actually internally
adopting something similar to what we
have proposed except they're doing it
again within the boundaries of the
current interface as a result I'm not
sure if the solution is going to be very
long-lasting I also wanted to add that
there is one research publication out
there that claims that they mounted row
hammer attack on a dim that implements
TRR according to the spec they could not
you don't know whether the dim dust here
or not because you're unless you work
for the memory manufacturer but
according to the spec they implement ER
and they were able tomorrow hammer still
any comment on the the resilience of
attack resilience against attack of PTR
r versus TR our pseudo trusted very
fresh versus trust ergo refresh ok
what's the exact difference in to intel
has both specified marketed both both as
specifications that manufacturers can
comply with but not all of those details
are open exactly i think i think that's
that's part of the problem if the
details are not open it's very hard to
reason about the efficacy of the
solutions yeah that's all I can say so
you you briefly mentioned SRAM have
there have you have there been any
observations of of row hammer like
vulnerabilities in Israel not as far as
I know not in real systems but a lot of
people have shown that when they built
circuits that are very small feature
sizes SRAM also is vulnerable to heat
disturb errors but their protection
mechanisms I believe in existing SRAM's
in the processors because they're easy
to do right you don't need to change any
interfaces for those protection
mechanisms
so you mentioned about bringing down the
refresh time so but for that don't you
think you need to know the retention
times of each rose which may be widely
variable across rows you mean as a
solution to Rome so they're in there
basically increasing the refresh
frequency right but so basically you're
refreshing more often that's not a
problem
no but how often because the different
rows will have variable retention times
right due to manufacturing video that's
true but but the goal is their goal is
to basically refresh more frequently
such that you cannot do you know as many
activates with the Refresh interval okay
so it doesn't matter what the retention
time of they're always as long as you're
refreshing more frequently you don't
have any correctness issues in terms of
retention time loss but you do prevent
row hammer attacks okay but your
question I think how how much should you
increase your refresh according to our
results if your only solution is refresh
if you want to get rid of every single
error that we've seen in our in Arden's
you want to increase refresh rate by 7x
clearly they're not doing 7x they're
doing 2x in my opinion the the picture I
thought I showed you from the ThinkPad
BIOS was 2x that was your only option is
2x enough to get rid of all of the
errors that's a good question thank you
i sorry gotta ask this question
otherwise I couldn't couldn't follow
what you were you are talking about so a
while back when I'm still in the the
memory area my understanding is that row
hammer is caused by broken state in the
cell the band gap and then when you if
that's due to the metal layer if you use
poly silicon gauge the problem would
have been would have gone away right so
are you saying that today even today
like Samsung still using metal gate
that's why you say have this problem you
say is that a case so I cannot speak for
Samsung but yeah I think the causes that
I mentioned I think the cause that you
mentioned is still certainly valid okay
but the but the cause that I mentioned
it's really a combination of those
reasons okay so in multiple reasons that
as far as we know so your experiment was
done on later than even the latest
memory DRAM you still see the problem so
the the experiment that I reported are
from 2014 when we discovered extra 2012
okay 2014 we discovered the problem the
paper was published in 2014
latest DRAM we're looking into it there
he reports that latest DM also has these
errors that Stefan mentioned okay but
I'm I didn't know they'll say we didn't
do those studies ourselves I agree with
you if you if you can solve the problem
with changing the gate that would be
ideal
I'm not sure if it's going to be very
easy yeah yeah I agree
ECC is not a good solution to this
problem but probablistic I think the
probabilistic solution is may be cheaper
than the gate solution depending on the
constraints right okay so let me use the
last few minutes to conclude I think I
think we had a good discussion I'm not
going to go over these future challenges
unfortunately I think they're a bunch
but you can take a look at the slides
clearly refresh is going to be a
challenge and these slides actually have
a lot of detail on refresh if you're
interested in that I believe actually
there are retention time issues that may
be slipping into the fields but they may
be a bit harder to exploit than the
neural hammer at the
at least okay so how do we keep memory
secure I think there clearly we have
issues with diem we have issues with
flash memory although flash memory is a
little bit far from the system today but
emerging memory technologies actually
all have their reliability problems we
disturb write disturb many many
different reliability problems I think
we need some principled approaches we
need to somehow predict them prevent
such safety issues and I go back to the
galloping gertie which is the Tacoma
Narrows Bridge and people have developed
principle designs for this this actually
taught and civil engineering and physics
classes this particular bridge if you
will so how do we do it for me this is
my proposal I think we want to first
understand it's very difficult to really
model these effects if you want to go to
we've done a lot of circuit simulations
it's very very difficult to model
something like row hammer in in in
circuits you really need to somehow
predict based on other technologies
based on past experience so we want
solved methodologies for failure
modeling and discovery and I believe
this has to come from real devices both
at the small scale and large scale we
want to build models that can predict
the future we want to build models that
can predict from different devices
potentially how do we do that I think
there's an open research question I mean
you do want to develop metrics for
secure architectures eye and I say
secure over here but I think row hammer
demonstrated that's reliable to safety
and security I really very much related
to each other in this particular context
on top of this I believe in its
architects we need to have principle to
architecting of the system and memory we
need to have good partitioning of duties
across the stack so I believe ECC is not
a good solution because it's not a good
partitioning of the duties for it given
for the given problem of row hammer so
for each problem II to find the good
part thing and I believe flash memory is
a very good example where people
actually find the right partitioning so
they saw some of the problems of ECC but
they saw a lot of the problems with
voltage scaling as well and I believe
are a good architecting requires
figuring out these or potentially
preventing these unforeseen consequences
so how do you prevent for unforeseen
consequences I believe if we had better
program built in our memory controller
we wouldn't be refreshing our entire
memory by 2x or 4x
so if you had a better programmability
or very patch ability in the field we
would be doing better today and I think
this design needs to change basically
today
we don't have we're not really thinking
about security in our designs and the
hardware design we don't really design
with security I believe we need to
design to change that also and I didn't
talk about it but one of the ways of
having a design that can over time fix
some of these reliability issues is
having a design that can do online
testing which is essentially about
Fleiss of flash memory is doing today if
we have a mechanism to do online testing
in a low overhead manner in DRAM I think
that would go a long way because that
can enable also patch ability
potentially so that's what we're
building to understand we built these
infrastructures both for flash memory
and DRAM and we've been doing large
scale and small scale studies I believe
they're actually vulnerabilities in
flash memory also we've been exploring
some of these that are similar read
disturb is one example over there but
this is much much more much much harder
to exploit because flash memory is much
farther it's not directly exposed to the
programming model basically today but
there's a lot to do over there ok I'm
not gonna cover this I think there are
two other solution directions that I
will briefly talk about one is new
technology you can say oh why don't we
get rid of DRM and come up with some
other technology that doesn't have these
problems good luck I think it's
definitely good to exploit explore these
technologies about all of these
technologies as they scale to small size
they will have reliability problems and
they actually some of them have
endurance problems also and maybe the
second solution is even more interesting
you can embrace unreliable T but if
you've got to do it very carefully
basically you can design memories with
different reliable you know store data
intelligently a custom your secure data
may be in a very very reliable memory
that's much more expensive and your
unsecured data that doesn't require a
lot of security or reliability maybe in
the masses of memory that's not so
reliable but very low cost as long as
you that you do that partitioning rights
I think this is a really good
opportunity but how do you do that
partitioning rights is a difficult
question and I believe both of these
solutions over here require co.design
across the hierarchy so it may not be
that easy to adopt or both of these
solutions but I think there's a lot more
to do in the center genius reliable to
memory area that may be a good solution
so let me conclude
I believe memory reliability is reducing
there's a lot of data that is in the
field and that I've shown you
reliability issues open up security
vulnerabilities as well and these are
very hard to defend against or you come
up with very suboptimal solutions right
increasing the refresh rates across the
board row hammer is an example I believe
there will be more examples and I
believe this row hammers implicational
system security research are tremendous
and exciting and there's there continues
to be a lot of papers that are being
written on real hammer these days so
there's good news we have a lot more to
do clearly and I believe we need to come
up with principled methodologies and
designs to be able to solve problems
like this like row hammer and whatever
comes next after row hammer I think this
is one principle that we we will need to
adopt going forward somehow we need to
change the processor memory interface
somehow and have more intelligence in
the memory controller okay thank you
[Applause]